- Welcome and welcome back
to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Today's video is quite special.
We're going to talk about a topic
that I haven't covered a
lot yet on this channel.
We're going to talk
about investment banking,
and I invited a special
guest to this channel
to help me cover this topic.
It is Afzal.
Afzal is a former
Goldman Sachs consultant.
He will help you understand
what investment banking is all about.
He will discuss the key
divisions in investment banking
and also some tips,
what you can do to get into a job
like Goldman Sachs or other
bulge bracket banks as well.
Afzal has a YouTube channel
called Afzal Hussein,
I will link it below in
the video description.
He makes lots of great videos
on investment banking and related topics.
I can really recommend
you to check it out.
But now, without further
ado, let's jump in.
Let's learn what working
at investment banks
like Goldman Sachs looks like
and what you can do to
get such a job as well.
- Hey, thank you for tuning in today.
My name is Afzal Hussein
and I run a YouTube channel
called Afzal Hussein,
Heinrich will link it in
the video description below.
Long story short,
I graduated six, seven years ago now.
I went to a mid-tier university,
Queen Mary in London,
and I studied economics and finance.
My goal at uni
was to do as many spring weeks
and internships as possible.
Got my internship at Goldman Sachs
within their asset management business.
I did that for 10 weeks
and converted that into a full-time offer
after I graduated.
I joined Goldman's full-time
in the asset management
business as a salesperson,
and I did that for a few years
until I left to pursue
entrepreneurship full-time.
But I don't want to waste too much time,
I wanna get straight to the
value that I can add for you.
And what I want to do in this video
is explain to you a bit
about the investment banking division
at an investment bank,
the sales and trading division
and asset management and private banking,
because these are the four,
or four of the front office
divisions at an investment bank.
So you've got the front office,
which are revenue generating,
higher salaries, higher
bonuses, client facing.
And then you've got the back office,
things like human resources,
finance, operations, so on and so forth.
Why I want to focus on the
front office areas for you today
is because I get a lot of
management consultants,
a lot of consulting
interns, graduates, etc.,
who reach out to me and ask me
how can they break into investment banking
or how can they break
into asset management?
And so, I'll touch on all of these,
and then I'll touch on
some of the similarities
in the skillsets that you guys will have
as individuals with a
consulting background
or experience in the world of consulting.
And then, I'll touch on
some of the differences
between consulting and
working for an investment bank
so that you can kind of focus
on the key gaps that you need to fill
if you're ever interested in breaking in.
Without any further ado,
let's get straight into it.
The investment banking division
is basically corporate advisory.
What individuals do in the
investment banking division
is help companies raise money,
whether it's through equity,
issuing equity or issuing debt.
They help companies
restructure their business,
so they look at the company's
equity to debt ratio
and assess if a company can
be organized in a better way
in order to function more efficiently
and increase shareholder value.
And they help companies
merge or take over.
So corporate advisory in essence
focuses on all of these areas.
When you go into the
investment banking division
as a junior,
you are going to be heavily
focused on building models,
financial models and
valuation models on Excel,
and working on presentation
skills on Microsoft PowerPoint.
These are the two tools
that you're gonna be using
for the most part
in your first few years in the
investment banking division.
And so, naturally you
bring a lot of that over
from management consulting
to investment banking
because you do a lot of that
in the world of consulting anyways.
The hours in the
investment banking division
are the longest in the industry.
You would get in at like nine AM
and then you would leave
in your first few years,
midnight, one AM, two AM.
It's very, very long,
but as a result,
you get compensated with large bonuses
at the end of the year.
And so, if that's something
you're interested in,
it's something worth looking at.
I've done quite a few videos
on the work-life balance,
salaries, all of that,
those are on my channel,
you can check those
out in your spare time.
Then we've got the sales
and trading division.
This is the markets aspect or
area of the investment bank.
This is where you see
traders on the trading floor
glued into the financial markets.
They are basically creating markets
for clients who want to buy
or sell financial securities
and connecting them with
other clients or individuals
who want to buy and sell
financial securities.
The traders are on the trading floor,
there's salespeople on the trading floor,
there's researchers on the trading floor.
All of these people are
coming up with ideas,
executing ideas in order
to make a small commission
of the large sums of money
that the clients are trading.
So if you're interested
in getting stuck into
the financial markets,
whether that be as a
salesperson or a trader,
then this might be something
that you're interested in.
Typically you would get in really early
before the markets open,
so six or seven AM,
and then you would leave at
like five, six, seven PM.
And then you've got asset
management and private banking.
These areas basically manage money
over a longterm horizon for their clients.
The key difference is
in private banking or
private wealth management
your clients are high
net worth individuals.
So rich people,
celebrities, footballers, etc.
And then in asset management,
your clients are government organizations,
local authorities, insurance companies,
pension schemes, sovereign
wealth funds, etc., etc.
So large corporations
versus individuals and family offices.
In asset management and private banking,
you can be a salesperson
where you're managing client relationships
or you can be a product person,
an investment professional,
getting the money in
and investing it into
the financial markets.
There are a lot of people
who come from management consulting
that break into asset
management or investment banking
as salespeople, for example,
because they have those qualities
that allow them to build
client relationships.
They have interpersonal skills,
they're good communicators,
they're good team workers,
so on and so forth.
Key skills that are very
similar, PowerPoint presentation.
You use a lot in consulting,
you use a lot in banking, why?
Because a lot of the work that a bank does
or a consulting firm does is
pitch to clients on PowerPoint.
If you are very good at
Microsoft PowerPoint,
you will be able to work
faster, more efficiently,
and just impress your
seniors a lot easier.
And so, that's one key similarity
between the two industries.
Another one is Excel,
I'm not too sure how
much you guys use Excel
in management consulting.
I'm sure you use it quite a bit,
but it's heavily used in
investment banking division
and on the trading floor.
And so, if you are good on Excel,
then that will be a bonus.
In both worlds,
you go and manage client relationships,
you are pitching your ideas
and solutions to the clients,
and you're trying to help them, right?
And then in the process,
you take a fee for that service.
However, if you wanna move
from management consulting
to investment banking specifically,
it's important to understand
that in investment banking,
you need a good understanding
of accounting principles.
You need to be able to look
into the inner workings of a company
by reading its financial statements
and have an understanding
of what it all means.
That's what the investment bank does,
it takes all of that information
and puts it into the Excel models.
And then it predicts or estimates
the future performance of that company
in different scenarios.
In management consulting,
I'm not sure how much of that you do,
but if you're considering
breaking into banking,
it's always good to have
some background knowledge
in accounting principles and
financial statement analysis.
If you wanna make the transition
from management consulting to banking,
whether it's in asset management,
sales and trading,
private banking or the
investment banking division,
my advice to you,
three quick tips.
Make sure your cover letter is strong.
Make sure your CV is strong.
Make sure you network.
Talk to people in these industries,
whether it's through LinkedIn
or simply whatever it is.
Make sure you talk to them,
network, ask them questions,
because you'll be surprised
how much you can learn
from connecting with
people in the industry.
They will help you get further
than just trying to make
the transition on your own
without reaching out to people
or connecting with people.
If you made it this far in the video,
thank you so much.
If you wanna find out a bit more about me
or watch more of my videos,
I do videos on banking, finance,
careers and general
productivity lifestyle.
So head over to my channel,
Heinrich will link it in
the video description below.
Whatever stage you're at in your career,
whether you're not in university yet,
whether you're in uni
or if you're a graduate,
good luck with your journey.
Persistence is key.
Stay inspired, stay ambitious.
And yeah, thank you for
watching this video, thank you.
- So I hope you found
this video insightful.
If you have any questions,
just feel free to leave a comment below
in the comment section,
and I'm sure that Afzal
is going to regularly
look into your comments
and also answer all your questions.
In addition, as you know,
every comment that you
write really helps me
with the YouTube algorithm.
So every single comment
is much appreciated.
Similar to that,
if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
To see even more from me,
follow me on Instagram,
my handle is Firm Learning.
I also have a mailing list,
there is a signup link to that
in the video description below.
And I wanna say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Every member makes a significant
contribution to the work,
to the cause of this channel,
so your support is very much appreciated.
And if you are thinking about
becoming a member as well,
just hit the join button
next to the subscribe button
to learn what it's all about.
And yes, you have access
to some member only perks
if you join as a member.
Thank you to everybody
who watched until the end,
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to next week's video,
and until then,
enjoy the weekend, bye bye guys.